hello everyone we're here at the opening
ceremony for the Grantchester rabbit and
blitz here in Abidjan we're gonna have a
drawing of lots
there's lots of excitement building lots
of kids lots of fans as the best chess
players in the world are set to begin
well I'm very excited if the first leg
of the grand gesture well as probably
the strongest chess tournament has been
played in Africa's Grantchester
under the right direction I think it's
important that we are able to bring
chess all over the world having
conscious tour coming to Africa is
really big step putting Afrikaans a
chess match it's a good way of trying to
infer the chess here in Africa and I
think for all the locals it's an
opportunity that they have never had
before so I think it's very very good
for the trust culture low point
[Music]
and it said an exploit cotton for
Chesson so for sure it'll be a big
success
I'm hoping that the people of the
country bar will be inspired by it by
the games I will try and do my best to
pry that well that was a great opening
ceremony lots of excitement lots of fun
had by all a great way to begin the 2019
Grantchester